[Music]
this video is sponsored by raycon anyone
who's been in the anime community knows
that we're a fickle disagreeable bunch
who argue more than a sibling pair
trying to figure out whose turn it is on
the xbox
so it's a rare sight when a series comes
along that can make us all come together
and collectively say
yeah the show [ __ ] slaps it's been a
long time since the singular anime has
gripped our entire community
the same way that attack on titan has to
me winter 2021 was the
strongest singular season of anime we've
had in years but despite how stacked it
was despite
how many bangers came out this was
attack on titan's season to remember
previously i made a video called attack
on titan is incredible now going over
the show's evolution from seasons one to
three that has now become one of my most
viewed videos ever behind
some other series i did that i'm sure no
one remembers
oh hey look is that average that being
said now that the first part of season 4
has finally concluded
do i think the new season has lived up
to the legacy it's been building
over the last decade i mean
i guess if you want to get a little
technical about it
it's not like it's in the title of the
video or anything
why did i still start these videos with
some stupid rhetorical question
attack on titan final season has not
only matched what came before it but has
shot
straight past it to become a series i
don't think anyone envisioned it would
be when they first started it
and it is incredible
still okay that's the last callback i'm
gonna do the title of this video i swear
and look i'm not gonna pretend that
everyone hasn't already watched it and
given their two cents in the show and
this video is gonna be nothing more than
just throwing another fart into the wind
but [ __ ] you just let me gush so i can
move on with my life i'll try to keep
spoilers at a minimum for the new season
but for [ __ ] sake who am i kidding
it's attack on titan the thing is easier
to spoil than a black shirt at a [ __ ]
meetup there's probably going to be
something in here attack on titan is a
series that has continually changed and
grown
building upon the foundations of
previous seasons and i can safely say
that this final season is
the most distinctive season thus far we
are so far beyond anything the show was
initially set up as that is almost
unrecognizable
forget about an epic tale of humanity's
fight for survival against monsters it's
a complex political war thriller with
heroes and villains on either side with
no clear distinction of who or what you
should be rooting for
good guys have flaws bad guys are
sympathetic and you're just here sitting
in the middle being like
come on guys can't we all just get along
i mean it's like only a bit of casual
genocide nothing a nice cup of tea can't
fix
like there's been series before that
have changed up things as since
progressed but attack on titan final
season didn't just change up a few
characters and elements it's straight-up
just changed the entire [ __ ] genre of
the show and what blows my mind is how
it does this so casually while feeling
like a completely natural progression
season three may have been the payoff to
everything that was built up but season
four
is the evolution rewatching the entire
series from the beginning is actually
incredible how much foreshadowing and
small bits of information were scattered
throughout all the way back from season
one
it's so obvious that despite it being a
completely different series from when we
first started
this was the game plan all along
probably the biggest red herring of them
all was the fact that it was called
attack on titan in the first place at
this point we might as well just call it
attack on the [ __ ] geneva convention
or me and the boys at 2 am committing
war crimes but what continues to
surprise me is that no matter how much
things change
everything feels earned and i don't
think there's a better example of this
than aaron himself you remember erin
writes you know aaron kill all the
titans jaeger well this is him now
god damn fine wine wishes that could age
this well look at him my boy could be
sitting in front of levi being like oh
ah
called the fan girls huh but not for you
season four aaron is a completely
different beast to the character we knew
and here i thought
peak errand development before was arc
one aaron gets kidnapped arc two aaron
gets kidnapped arc three aaron gets
kidnapped arc
iv eren doesn't get kidnapped that's
some premium character the arc five
aaron kidnaps himself
[ __ ] sake aaron but no this isn't the
same aaron finnegan kidnaps jaeger we've
known from previous seasons this is a
battle-hardened war veteran who's not
afraid to make any sacrifices to achieve
his goal he's almost the complete
opposite of the person he was
but it just feels right remember in that
final season of game of thrones where
one of the main characters who had stood
up for justice and morals had a big
moment where seemingly out of nowhere
they decided to do a horrendous act that
went against
everything the character had previously
stood for and you were just left there
thinking
what the hell where did this come from i
don't even think a nice cup of tea can
fix this
i always look back to that part and
think how powerful and defining that
moment could have been
if it actually felt earned because
that is exactly how i feel watching
aaron [ __ ] them kids jager
he's been built up to be the boogeyman
of this world and he truly personifies
it
you see that same headstrong idealistic
character you've been following
betraying his friends
sacrificing the people closest to him
and even killing civilians
mikasa is like aaron do you know
you've just killed innocent children and
cool as a cucumber aaron's like yo wanna
see me do a backflip into that crowd
erin no
but you know what i get it throughout
the series you've seen aaron taking
l after l after l after [ __ ] l
this man has such a big obsession with
elves he might as well get a [ __ ]
death note you've seen his confidence
get shaved away slowly but surely from
that loudmouth angry kid who started off
as that by the end of season three
you could tell that something big was
changing inside of him
i don't care who you are that many elves
changes a man so
even though we don't yet know the exact
motives for his actions you can totally
see
why he ended up like this and it was
such a treat to see such a bold
character change
absolutely pay off and honestly erin
i've had enough of your [ __ ] yeager it's
just one of the many in the rich cast
that gets equal care and attention
there are so many characters so many
moving parts yet never does it feel
excessive or overbearing
it's so rare that a series juggling so
many parts doesn't get crushed under the
weight of its own ambition but it
somehow balances at all
this is the kind of [ __ ] where people
will still be making character analysis
videos five years after the show's ended
and we still probably wouldn't have
explored every little nuance of this
story
it feels like isiah spent all this time
setting up all these dominoes in all the
right places and all he's done is go
and we're just here marveling at these
dominoes toppling down one by one
and yes i did choose this analogy so i
can show some cool domino's clips i mean
look at this who doesn't love seeing
dominoes
all right back to anime for the big
explosive set pieces attack on titan is
known for there were equally as many
compelling scenes just based around
dialogue which shows how strong these
foundations are there are characters i
love there are some characters i really
[ __ ] hate but what i hate even more
is that isayama somehow successfully
managed to make me give them a shred of
sympathy like everyone seems to be
hating on gabby for certain obvious
reasons but i totally get why she's
there she's just season one erin that
spawned on the enemy team and it makes
perfect sense why she is
the way she is aggravating and all i
feel like people forget that the
character you dislike and a bad
character are not always one and the
same with previous seasons you'd go in
with baited breath not knowing which
characters would make it out alive but
now not only do you not know who will
make it out alive you don't even know
who you want to make it out alive
and it's honestly just a treat to see a
series doing so many things
right which brings us to the awkward
topic of the anime adaptation itself
because uh well this ended up being a
bit of a bombshell for topic didn't it
with one of the most popular anime
franchises of all time going through a
studio change in its final season
there were always going to be a lot of
eyes picking apart every little detail
but
my god did it turn into kind of a [ __ ]
show at times
people had a problem with the animation
the music choices the [ __ ] opening
like
what like i know this is meant to be a
hauntingly beautiful visual spectacle
showcasing the horrors of war
but like loki is a bit of a banger right
like if this came on in the club you bet
your arse i'm [ __ ] jamming to just
like ah
ah ah god damn nothing like breaking the
geneva convention
on the dance floor so when you hear
about animators getting harassed or
episode directors having to private
their twitter
your gut reaction is to be like attack
on titan ten out in adaptation [ __ ] the
man children would have sex with cg
aaron any day but now that everything's
said and done
i think it's fine to acknowledge without
an attack on anyone though the
adaptation of the final season
was kind of missing that same oomph i
think it's easy to just point at the
obvious culprit and go
guys attacking titan is being attacked
by bad siege
but honestly i don't actually think the
cg was bad in fact i think the cg looks
way better than any of the cg we got
from previous seasons because what the
[ __ ] is this
i think the real difference is that for
every shot of a janky looking colossal
titan we got moments like this
or this and we
kind of didn't get anything like this at
all in the final season one of my
favorite fights previously was aaron vs
reiner's striker vs grappler fight
because i thought it was absolutely cool
to see
such subtle details being put into the
techniques being used in a martial arts
brawl between
giants and there's just no way anything
like this could have been achieved with
the 3d models that were used a lot of
subtle details and expression is lost
when you rely on the rigid 3d models
meaning the titans can just look kind of
lifeless at times
all you need to do is to compare the
mali scenes to the original release
trailer just to see how good this
could have looked i absolutely
understand why there was far more cgus
with titans being one of the hardest
things to animate especially on a tight
schedule but i do feel that from a
purely animation standpoint there wasn't
that
holy [ __ ] moment that we used to get
instead of taking the original source
material and enhancing it it feels like
we got
just the exact right amounts needed to
not detract from it
i am not unhappy with the work mapper
did at all but i would be absolutely
lying if i didn't miss the draw dropping
sequences studio which provided that
elevated isayama's work to a whole new
level and i know
that that is because the production
schedule that was given just did not
allow them to go above and beyond but
part of me just kind of wish that they
did have more time to continue that same
quality
as it stands i feel like the final
season and the moments that defined it
was not
carried by the adaptation but how
[ __ ] great the story of attack on
titan was in the first place
and honestly if that's the biggest
negative i can think of that ain't too
bad
with the show this hyped and popular
there are always going to be some people
who think it's overrated or didn't
affect them in the same way
but honestly i think this is one of the
few shows where i'd say
yeah it deserves the hype new anime fans
are going to be calling this one of
their favorite anime of all time and
veteran weaves with hundreds of shows
under their belts will probably be
saying the same
seeing the reception to this final
season was kind of surreal to me because
it's the first time i've seen an anime
that was perceived like it was nion
mainstream
sure we've had singular anime episodes
and moments blow up on the internet
before but i've never seen an anime
seemingly trend every single week
whether something big
happened or not the initial hype that
the first season got was astronomical
when it first came out and was untouched
by future seasons
until seemingly now which i think has
not only matched it but blown
past it's become kind of a staple of
mainstream nerd culture itself
if you watch anime you are watching it
if you don't watch anime you are
probably watching it as well there was
this kind of unspoken understanding on
social media that
everyone was watching attack on titan
and if you weren't well
that was kind of on you i was ready for
attack and titan season 4 to be big
but i was thoroughly unprepared for how
big it actually
got i said previously that attack on
titan had the potential to become
the modern classic and at this point it
pretty much already
is a classic the only thing left it
really needs to do is to land its ending
and i'm not even talking about a 900
degree pop shove it into a handstand
kind of ending that blows everyone's
mind and revolutionizes the medium
forever
after everything it's done after
everything it's doing
all it really needs to do is to land on
two
feet and i say this knowing full world
that by the time this video is out
the final chapter of the manga will have
been released an attack on titan
in one form will have already ended so
the manga readers will already know if
it achieved that
but as someone who patiently stayed
faithful to the anime watching this
final season made me feel something i
hadn't felt in a very long time
watching this felt like i was being a
part of something bigger
there are moments in film and tv that
have left their mark on pop culture
forever
it wasn't just a broadcasted piece of
entertainment when it first came out
it was an entire event and this kind of
feels like that moment for us
anime fans not just another great show
that we'll fall away and move on from
after it's over
but something that will leave a deep
imprint on our entire community for
years
or even decades to come that's
attack on titan and we're going to have
to wait a year to see
how it plays out we're not just watching
another great anime coming to an end
we're watching history being made
hey guys hope you enjoyed that video
thank you again to raycon for sponsoring
me today
you know what guys if you're like me and
you're like [ __ ] the haters
this attack on titan opening [ __ ]
slaps i want to listen to this on repeat
all day every day well raycon might just
be the thing for you
raycon is disrupting the electronics
industry by designing premium wireless
earbuds for half the price without
compromise they give you six hours of
play time seamless bluetooth pairing
more bass and a more compact design for
a comfortable noise isolating fit
from the way they design their products
to the way they price them they
prioritize the customer experience from
start to finish
right now they offer their premium
earbuds in a variety of colors with
different fit options with no
dangly wives or anything like that the
company was co-founded by ray j and
celebrities like snoop dogg and mike
tyson are obsessed with raycon
and don't forget they have a 45 day free
return policy as well
honestly i've had this pair since they
first started sponsoring me last year
and the reason i keep taking raycon
sponsorships is because
i actually genuinely use them and i
still use them to this day
so what are you waiting for click the
link in the description or go to
byraycon.com for fifteen percent
off your order that's biorecon dot com
slash giggup for fifteen percent
off and yeah that is that i really hope
this video didn't come out too late
because uh
i know the anime finished a few weeks
ago and the manga
of attack on titan is now done this is
literally the end of an era you know
i've completely stayed off social media
so i do not know how the ending has gone
down but uh
really hope the ending been [ __ ] bad
because that would mean the ending of
this video is gonna be pretty awkward
but you know what i guess i'll be
finding out next year to see uh
if this really does go down to the
classic or not please if you're a manga
reader do not spoil in the comments
section but you know what i know what
your margaritas are like i am not going
to take the risk
i am just not going to read the comment
section and i urge any anime only fans
to do the same as well so
anyway with that said that's it from me
i've been gigak and i will see you all
next time